[Music]
the kingdom known to us by the name of
Korea and by the natives called Jo sung
[ __ ] and sometimes cao lu li reaches
from 34 to 44 degrees of north latitude
being about 150 leagues in length from
north to south about 75 in breadth from
east to west
therefore the koreans represented in the
shape of a long square like a playing
card the houses of the koreans of
quality are stately but those of the
common sort are very mean nor are they
allowed to build as they please
no man can cover his house with tiles
unless he have leave to do so they built
with wooden posts or pillars with the
interval between filled up with stone up
to the first storey the rest of the
structure is all dogged without and
covered on the inside with white paper
glued on the floors are all vaulted and
in winter they make a fire underneath so
that they are always as warm as a stove
this video is sponsored by Magellan TV
the documentary streaming service can't
go outside under lockdown so if you're
trapped inside like me Salamun cocoa and
you don't know what to do with your time
maybe now's a good time to try Magellan
and for those of you who are signed up
to Magellan here is my personal
documentary recommendation to help pass
the time
Confucius creator of the golden rule
an excellent primer on Confucius and his
life story those of you that haven't
signed up yet
Magellan has the widest range of History
content available anywhere amongst lots
of other genres many available in high
quality 4k click on the link in the
description for an exclusive month-long
free trial for voices of the past
viewers thanks the nobility have always
an apartment forward where they receive
their friends and lodge their
acquaintances and there they divert
themselves there being generally before
their houses a large square or base
caught with a fountain or fish pond and
a garden with covered walks the woman's
apartment is in the most retired part of
the house that nobody may see them
tradesmen and the chief townsman
generally have our storehouse adjoining
to their mansion house where they keep
their goods and treat their friends with
tobacco and rice spirits there are
virtuous women among them who are
allowed the liberty of seeing people and
going into company and to feasts but
they sit by themselves and opposite to
their husbands they have scarce any more
household goods that are absolutely
necessary
there are in the country and abundance
of taverns and pleasure houses to which
the Koreans resort to see women dance
sing and play upon musical instruments
in summer they take this recreation in
cool groves under close shady trees they
have no particular houses to entertain
passengers and travelers but he who
travels goes and sits down where night
overtakes him near the palings of the
first house he comes out where though it
may not be a great man's house they
bring him boiled rice and dressed meat
enough for his supper when he goes from
thence he may stop at another house and
at several yet on the great road to
Seoul there are houses where those that
travel on public affairs have lodging
and diet on the public account the
Koreans are very much addicted to
stealing and so apt to cheat and lie
that there is no trusting them they
think they have done a good action when
they have over reached a man and
therefore fraud is not infamous among
them yet if a man can prove that he has
been cheated in a bargain of houses cows
or any other thing whatsoever
he may be righted there will be three or
four months after nonetheless they are
silly and credulous and we might have
made them believe anything we would
because they are great lovers of
strangers but chiefly the religious men
the aren effeminate
people and show very little courage in
resolution when they are put to it at
least we were told so by several
credible persons who were witnesses to
the havoc the Emperor of Japan made in
their country when he slew their king
they're not ashamed of cowardice and
lament the misfortune of those that must
fight they've often been repulsed with
loss when they have attempted to plunder
some European vessel that has been cast
on their coasts being bound for Japan
they abhor blood and Fly when they meet
with any they are much afraid of the
sick and particularly of those that have
contagious dis tempest and therefore
they presently remove them whether they
are in the town or country and put them
into little straw hovels in the middle
of fields there nobody talks to them but
only those that are to look after them
who give notice to passengers to keep
off and when the sick man has no friends
to take care of him the others rather
let him die than they will come near him
when there is a plague in one town or
village the avenues to it are shut up
with a hedge of briars and brambles and
they lay some on the top of the houses
where there are any sick so that all
people may know it they might when they
are sick make use of the simples that
grow in their country but the people are
not acquainted with them and almost all
the physicians are employed by the great
ones so the poor who cannot be at that
charge make use of blind men and
conjurors in whom they once reposed such
great confidence that they followed them
everywhere across rivers and rocks and
particularly into the temples of the
idols where they called upon the Devils
but this custom was abolished by the
Kings order in the year 1662
[Music]
before the Tartar subdued this kingdom
it was full of luxury and debauchery the
koreans whole business being eating and
drinking and giving themselves up to all
nudists but now that the tatars and
japanese tyrannize over them they have
enough to do to live when a year proves
bad because of the heavy tribute they
pay particularly to the Tartar who comes
three times a year to receive it they
believe there are but twelve kingdoms or
countries in the whole world which once
were all subject and paid tribute to the
emperor of china but they all made
themselves free since the tartar
conquered China he not being able to
subdue them they called the tartar TXA
and rnk and our country phnom penh kook
which is the name of chinese give to
portugal and therefore not knowing us
they give us the same name having learnt
it within these fifty or sixty years
since when the japanese told them to
plant tobacco its dress and make use of
it for till then it was unknown to them
and they telling them the seat of it
came from nan pang kook they often
called tobacco Nam pan koi they take so
much at present that the very children
practice it at four or five years of age
and there are very few men or women
among them that do not smoke when first
brought them they bought it for its
weight in silver and for that reason
they looked upon Nam pan kook as one of
the best countries in the world
their writings give us an account that
there are four score and four thousand
several countries but most of them to
not believe it and say that if that was
so every little island in the land must
pass for a country it being impossible
they say for the Sun to light so many in
a day when we name some countries to
them they laughed at us affirming that
we only talked of some town or village
their geographical knowledge of the
coasts reaching no further than Siam by
reason of the little traffic they have
with strangers further than that from
them they have scarce any trade but only
with the Japanese and with the people of
an island of Tsushima the Koreans also
have some trade at Peking and in the
northern parts of China but it is very
chargeable because they only go thither
by land and on horseback the great ones
and chief merchants buy and pay for all
with money but the meaner sort deal only
with rice and other commodities by way
of barter they know no money but their
Cassy's and those pass only on the
frontiers of China they pay silver by
weight in little ingots like those we
bring from Japan
[Music]
kindred are not allowed to marry within
the fourth degree they make no love
because they are married at eight or ten
years of age and the young maids from
that time live in their father-in-law's
house they live in the husband's
father's house till they have learned to
get their living or to go on their
family the day a man marries he mounts
on horseback attended by his friends and
having ridden around the town he stops
at his bride's door where he is very
well received by the kindred who take
the bride and carry her to his house
where the marriage is consummated
without any other ceremony
though a woman has born her husband many
children it is in his power to put her
away when he pleases and to take another
but the woman has not the same privilege
unless you can get it by law to say the
truth
they make no great account of their
wives and use them little better than
slaves turning them away for the least
faults and sometimes on bare pretenses
and then they force them to take their
children whom those poor wretches are
bound to maintain the nobility in all
free man in general take great care of
the education of their children and put
them very young to learn to read and
write to which that nation is much
addicted they use no manner of rigor in
their method of teaching but manage all
by fair means giving their scholars an
idea of learning and of the worth of
their ancestors and telling them how
honourable those are who by this means
have raised themselves to great fortunes
which breeds emulation and then makes
them studious is wonderful to see how
they improve by these means and how they
expand the writings they give them to
read where in all their learning
consists besides this private study
there is in every tower a house where
the nobility
according to ancient customs of which
they are very tenacious take care to
assemble the youth to make them read the
history of the country and the
condemnations of great men who have been
put to death for their crimes to perfect
them in their learning
there are assemblies kept yearly in two
or three towns of each province where
the scholars appear to get employment
either by the pen or by the sword the
governors of towns send Abel deputies
there there to examine them and choose
the best qualified and according to the
report to them they write to the king
the aspiring to these honors is often
the ruin of the candidates because of
the presence they make and treats they
give to gain reputation obtain votes
some there are also that die by this way
parents are very indulgent to their
children and in return a much respected
by them it is otherwise with the slaves
who have a little care of their children
because they know they will be taken
from them as soon as they are able to
work or do any business when a freeman
dies his children mourn three years and
during all that time they live as
austerely as the religious men are not
capable of any employment and if any of
them is in a post he must quit it it is
not permitted them to be in a passion or
to fight much less to be drunk they
never go without a great cane or cudgel
in their hand which serves to
distinguish who they are in mourning for
the cane denoting the father at a stick
to the mother during all this time they
never wash as soon as one dies his
kindred run about the streaks shrieking
and tearing their hair then they take
special care to bury him honorably in
some part of a mountain shown them by a
fortune-teller
they generally bury their dead in spring
and autumn as for those that die in
summer they put them into a thatched Hut
raised upon four stakes or they leave
them till the rice harvest is over they
have conjurer's diviners or soothsayers
who assure them whether the dead are at
rest or not and whether the place where
they are buried is proper for them in
which point they are so superstitious
that it often happens that they will
remove them two or three times when a
father is four school years of age he
declares himself incapable of managing
his estate and resigns it up to his
children who maintain their father and
always pay him a great deal of respect
when the eldest has taken possession of
the estate he builds a house at the
public expense for his father and mother
where he lodges and maintains them
the king told us it was not the customs
of Korea to suffer strangers to depart
the kingdom that we must resolve to end
our days in his dominions that he would
provide us with all necessaries then he
ordered us do such things before him as
we were best skilled in as singing
dancing and leaping after our mana next
he caused us to have meat given us which
was well enough after their manner and
gave each of us two pieces of cloth to
clothe us after their fashion the next
day we were all sent before the general
of their forces who would add weatr II
to tell us that the King had put us into
his life guards and that as such he
would allow us seventy catties of rice a
month every one of us had a paper given
him in which we were set down his name
his age his country which professionally
to follow perform what now he was all
than their character sealed with the
king's Great Seal in the generals which
is nothing but the print of a hot iron
together with this commission they
delivered to each a musket powder and
ball with orders to give a volley before
the general every 1st and 4th day of the
month to be always ready to march into
the field with him whether the king went
or upon any other account most of the
great men being fond of novelty invited
us to dine at their homes to see us
exercise after our manner and to make us
shoot and dance but above all their
wives and children were eager to see us
because the meaner sort of the island of
quell part had spread abroad a rumour
that we were monstrous and that when we
drank we were forced to tuck up our
noses behind our ears these absurd tales
were the cause that the better sort of
people at soul were amazed to see us
better shape than the people of their
own country
[Music]
you